die provinz leon im nordwesten spaniens
sie sind schon seit sieben uhr auf den
beinen
martin seine lebensgefährtin maja und
die beiden kinder 26 kilometer wollen
sie heute zurücklegen auf dem camino wie
die pilger ihn hier nennen den berühmten
jakobsweg im norden spaniens und hier
hat man einfach die ruhe man kann total
abschalten der weg der verzaubert ein so
ein bisschen alle gehen in die gleiche
richtung und das hat man im leben nie
der camino ist die finale etappe des
jakobsweges eines europäischen netzes
auf pilgerwegen durch viele länder
weisen die jakobsmuschel nach santiago
de compostela dem zielort des
jakobsweges im westen der region
galicien
dorthin wollen auch martin maja und die
beiden töchter 300 kilometer in drei
wochen bei 35 grad im schatten eine
körperliche grenzerfahrung gerade
deswegen hat das pilgern für sie etwas
befreiendes pilgern scheint vielen etwas
zu geben dass sie im alltag nicht finden
mehr als 250.000 menschen pilgerten 2015
auf dem jakobsweg was dreimal so viele
wie vor gut zehn jahren
der alte pilgerpfad ist zu einem
eldorado für
werne sinnsucher geworden auch stefan
albus war auf dem jakobsweg unterwegs
der journalist hat ein buch darüber
geschrieben was das pilgern mit einem
macht und vor allem warum mittlerweile
so viele menschen pilgern darauf gibt
das buch antworten
ich glaube dass wir in einer zeit leben
in der der mensch die persönlichkeit
immer unwichtiger wird die arbeit wird
immer dichter man muss immer mehr
arbeiten für dasselbe geld der stress
steigt und immer mehr menschen haben das
gefühl moment mal in meinem leben geht
es gar nicht mehr um mich was kann ich
da machen
wie komme ich da raus wie kann ich
wieder fuß fassen wie kann ich mich
wieder spüren
der grundstein des jakobsweges wurde vor
genau 1200 jahren gelegt mit der
bestattung die reliquien des apostels
jakobus des älteren christen pilgerten
fortan nach santiago um sich ihrer
schulden zu entledigen
religiosität ist heute weniger wichtig
es zählt anderes auf dem pilgerweg
finden viele leute zu sich selbst und
selbsterkenntnis ist durchaus ein erster
wichtiger schritt zur spiritualität wenn
man sich auf den weg macht auf einen weg
macht von dem man weiss seit 1000 jahren
gehen da leute lang um spirituelle
erfahrungen zu machen
ich glaube dann fühlt man sich mit
diesen menschen irgendwie innerlich
verbunden dieses gefühl sich einzureihen
in eine tausendjährige geschichte
das ist einfach großartig
in deutschland löste der bestseller ich
bin dann mal weg im jahr 2006 einen
pilger boom aus darin beschreibt der
deutsche entertainer hape kerkeling
seine reise auf dem jakobsweg die später
auch fürs kino verfilmt wurde kam
alleine klar
ich hab's kapiert eigentlich könnte ich
jetzt nach hause fahren
aber warum sollte ich
ein unentbehrliches accessoire auf dem
jakobsweg ist der pilgerpass die stempel
bekommt man in herbergen und kirchen am
wegesrand
wer nachweisen kann mindestens 100
kilometer gelaufen zu sein bekommt in
santiago de compostela eine pilger
urkunde die abgelegenen dörfer am camino
erleben seit dem anstieg der
pilgerzahlen einen wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung vielerorts in pilgerherbergen
entstanden auch maja martin und die
kinder übernachten in einer herberge die
unterkünfte sind einfach der heimische
überfluss ist weit entfernt
für viele ein lehrreiches erlebnis ist
man kein anderer mensch aber man weiß
dass man mit wenig sachen am tag leben
kann man braucht das alles gar nicht
alles nur was man auf dem rücken trägt
ist das wichtige für den tag
am nächsten tag geht es weiter richtung
westen nach santiago de compostela
schritt für schritt auf der suche nach
sinn